okay guys hi my name is Jess McDonald
I'm Zuri tea and we're back for another
week of house of horrors where we play
horror games on a weekly basis which is
why I said a week today we're playing a
game called the last door which is an
indie game being released in periodic
episodic installments it's now up to
season 2 episode 1 but we're going to be
playing season 1 episode 1 you can grab
it from their website the last door calm
it's by the game kitchen it's I got
super pixel graphics and I don't mean
like kind of pixel I mean like all-out
pixel graphics my life is on a course
that I can't escape from dude this is
like kind of grim sounds like Lincoln
Park lyrics it's too late for me too
yeah well it kind of matches what's
going on oh geez
yo sincerely and Denis Beach
did you just oh oh yeah that's the pixel
death in the first two minutes the
soundtrack is amazing [ __ ] Carlos
good stuff comments I didn't know
anything was the owner of such
properties I guess I can only notion
rain coming in sweet worried about
Anthony I have to find him
Anthony's supe dead birds a murder of
crows hmm
eating he's too dark okay even he has
logic it's not going to the dark
is there a scrolling screen oh yes there
is good this is gonna set us up
something I feel a lamp a lamp I love ya
food is waiting for you okay so I open
the window maybe the cat will come did
they set up a time period for this yes
it's in 1890 me like a curb ah pretty
bad I knew a matches burn everything
that's your way in the future or in
browser if you don't know yeah no way I
can baby okay thank you
was that hesitation oh good a record oak
robot Crobat Crobat Crobat Crobat yeah
soothing tune
oh my gosh it's me it's Kurt yeah this
seems like a good uh oh okay thank you
God's sake what happened here yeah hey
wake up you know you feel we don't want
that
yeah often paint thinner what what old
dam Kersey's gone there's a dying yes
they went inside let's take the car to
the lake maybe he wants to eat it
Shh freaking out I'm just gonna feed you
- thanks we need something that holds
the window oh hey oh yes me that was
unexpected yes
cat meowing I'm coming for you kitty
kins oh goodness
yeah look it came out through the hole I
think it went into the hole its eyes
gracious bad kitty
a dark cloak a mosque in a knife
I keep trading one strange tool for
another strange yeah that sounded gnarly
oh man
oh yes are dead oh god no Anthony no
just asked you to go immediately back to
the boarding school where we made that
pact
seeing is believing to have it don't
forget it always evade him speak now or
for if you want us to play to see
headstand give us each day our daily
bread
oh I'm naked hahaha he's gonna go to
sleep now and pray oh oh okay Lord and
lead us not into temptation I don't want
you to do that again
oh but deliver us from evil hanging two
three now wake up wake up
oh he's wearing his hat and click this
time that's because we're a fancy man
grab yours Juliette Holloway hello a
stern eagle lies on the floor mine why I
don't understand did you order to bury
corpses here why instead why are you
repeating yourself boy understand amidst
of it the building is now used as a
nursing home run by nuns a former
student here Hey excuse the interruption
mr. Baldwin I'll leave you with your
work so it's a nursing home and then you
bury the people who died in the nursing
home next to it
she was cold keep me out honor she just
let me take my lettuce you see that poor
man is still obsessed with his wife he
went except that she left him months ago
she's lying
yes all the letters I wrote to do Juliet
you never posted them but why Mary why
would you do such a thing but how could
you be so cruel I had to do it Matthew
you refused to see how inappropriate and
mad she is for you farewell brother
[ __ ]
man we just broke up a family cool boy
we broke up a family to get a coin yeah
we did totes where it's a photograph
with my graduating class I see myself oh
yes there is
pee my wonder said about this photo it
was a one megapixel camera but he went
to the school with Anthony who was the
guy that hung himself yeah
and this first they swore some sort of
bow our buddy hey buddy
it was waved at you could I talk to you
I'm afraid that's impossible
Monsignor has left strict instructions
that he not be disturbed
okay want this every day I hear them cry
pray scream and die and what for
excuse me sir oh god she's gonna kill us
all don't die oh come on hey look good
cool music box I'm lined up for you oh
yeah listen oh what a beautiful melody
man I feel like such a good person right
now Arthur man I was just doing anything
I could to save her dry leaves no
there's lots of water going down there
yay I guess oh yeah for shooting peace I
love that you have just pick up a trunk
of Burke and Merrill Nonna's habit and
walking stick oh they belong to the
NHANES spoke to by the window uh-oh I
hope she's not dead please okay I got
some flotsam
that's probably where did she go
she's trying to naked none another dead
put a net in it oh good alright net to
worry
yeah alright take your coin back it's
not helping needle wake the sleeping kid
with the stick that's Amy oh my god oh
my god you imagine without the nuns
noticing you try and get me madam feed
enough so so that I can be embraced by
the deepest of dreams and in that way
stop the rhythm of my heart oh you left
a note
oh there's an art on the bed well
Wow the guy outside he's killing them
nice good don't worry about it what he's
petrified massive madness um did you
still need morphine even itself I think
the curries are gonna come in oh dear oh
my god the crows hojae colleagues I've
decided change the venue for tonight's
meeting have you noticed a lounge behind
the small table the dining room
sleepytime night night night when going
through a bush mr. radish radish mr.
wolf mr. vulture and this is snake who
are having a heated argument while we're
trying to decide here's who of us will
have the pleasure to eat you up
I got it we're not organized a race the
first who arrives at the forest clearing
will have the privilege to eat me mr.
rabbit happy to trick them started
running at high speed in the opposite
direction of the Predators frightened
birds flew and everything would go ah
rabbits rabbits rabbits [ __ ] [ __ ]
Ron dude go away
oh dear looks like a bit of Satanism not
only absolution is divided by the flames
don't burn yourself you met men
oh dear madam in it's a game you can
play for free if you want to add the
last door calm you can donate money
otherwise you can just play the chapters
that are come out so far all the way up
to the very last one and it's pretty
cool so check it out next week it's
actually a public holiday in Australia
so we will be back at the same time but
possibly no I um
but will likely be watching joining you
guys again in chat so thank you very
much for watching and as always let us
know what you thought about the game in
the comments or if you have suggestions
for us and you want us to play any
particular game we'll revisit an old one
we are all for it thanks very much and
we'll hopefully see you again next week
thanks guys bye
you